comment prévenir l'obésité chez l'enfant
voilà une question qui était au coeur
des consultations aujourd'hui ouvertes à
l'occasion de la journée nationale de
dépistage qui étaient organisées dans
l'ensemble du pays
première information ce soir le
dépistage doit être le plus précoce
possible car l'obésité s'installe le
plus souvent avant l'âge de 6 ans c'est
le dossier de ce soir il est signé
pierre monnet gier les frères et manger
sous quelle forme
et bien non pas de chantilly mais au
moins cinq fruits et légumes par jour
pas toujours facile à avaler j'aime pas
le verdier
je n'aime pas la courgette
et jean talon mais il ya urgence
aujourd'hui en france un enfant sur six
est obèse c'est deux fois plus qu'il ya
dix ans l'obésité s'installe le plus
souvent entre 2 et 6 ans d'où
l'importance d'un dépistage précoce et
la nécessité de responsabiliser les
parents
au début on sait pas trop comment faire
pour calmer un bébé qui pleure et on lui
donne facilement à manger alors que
c'est pas toujours le problème est qu'on
a du mal ensuite aimer nos enfants en
leur disant non tu n'as pas besoin de
manger parce que ton corps n'en a plus
besoin
les causes de l'obésité sont connus - de
sport toujours plus de biscuits et de
sodas les conséquences elles ne sont pas
toujours prises en compte les personnes
en surpoids sont trois fois plus
sujettes à des complications
cardiovasculaires
elles voient leur risque de diabète x 9
et leur espérance de vie réduite de 13
ans dans cet établissement spécialisé on
accueille de jeunes obèses pour 5 à 6
mois d'internât diététique perdu combien
les plus beaux villages ou manon hockey
ban ki moon pour ces ados les rondeurs
ont aussi des conséquences
psychologiques qu'on avait un peu marre
à l'école des moqueries ça m'embêtait
épiait pas confiance en moi du tout ça
m'a appris à vivre avec d'autres gens
avoir une confiance aux modèles qui perd
le peu que je voulais la recette est
simple manger varié en famille ou entre
amis et toujours avec plaisir
oui